[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans les semaines dans le
monde sur france 24 ont fait le tour d
une de l'actualité internationale avec
nos éditorialistes j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés patricia allemonière
bonsoir patricia grand reporter
également en face de vous laurent
larcher bonsoir journaliste à la croix
changer de l'afrique on va voir la une
de la croix s'afficher justement pour
voir quels sujets vous traiter en une ce
soir donc c'est le mali le mali dont
tombe bien sûr veux bien sûr parler
beaucoup pendant cette émission avec
nous également charles haquet bonsoir
rédacteur en chef du service monde de
l'express l'express en une également
vous titrez sur le co vite pourquoi ce
n'est pas fini bienvenue à vous
également merci lors six mois et c'est
avec nous parce qu'à l'aide de paris
lors bonsoir de cartooning for peace
et on va tout de suite faire un petit
est sommaire cet historique la france et
ses alliés européens se retire du mali
sans pour autant quitter le sahel
emmanuel macron récuse l'idée d'un échec
de l'opération barkan la junte malienne
demande à la france de retirer ses
troupes sans délai
très fortes tensions autour de la crise
russo ukrainienne dans le dombass les
bombardements s'intensifient la russie
assure avoir entamé le retrait de
soldats mais les pays occidentaux jugent
que les mouvements de troupes reflète
une offensive imminente
la hongrie et la pologne vont elles se
soumettre aux règles européennes l'union
européenne dispose d'une nouvelle arme
un mécanisme qui permet de bloquer les
fonds européens attribués aux pays qui
menacent l'état de droit
et puis l'afghanistan six mois après la
chute de kaboul et la prise du pouvoir
par les talibans le pays est meurtri par
la famine l'économie sinistrée les
femmes banni des écoles de l'espace
public et du monde du travail joe biden
prévoit de consacrer la moitié des
actifs afghans à l'indemnisation des
familles victimes des attentats du 11
septembre 2001 cette décision suscite
l'indignation des afghans
c'est donc historique à vous le savez la
france et ses alliés européens à se
retire du mali sans pour autant quitter
le sahel emmanuel macron récuse l'idée
d'un échec de l'opération abarkan le
divorce entre la france et le mali est
consommé la junte demande d'ailleurs
maintenant à la france de retirer ses
troupes sans délai et résultat de neuf
ans d'engagement français au mali n'ont
pas été satisfaisants selon as les
autorités maliennes on écoute emmanuel
macron le porte parole du gouvernement
manière
cette décision qui est le fruit d'une
évolution de la situation politique et
des choix souverain de la junte en
responsabilité au mali s'appliquera donc
elle s'appliquera simplement en bon
ordre pour que nous continuions
d'assurer pendant cette période la
sécurité de la mine usma et la sécurité
de toutes nos forces armées déployées
aujourd'hui au mali avec sécurité avec
laquelle je ne transigerai pas une seule
seconde où le gars de ces manques moins
réputés des accords de défense
gouvernement invite les autorités
françaises à
retirer sans délai les forces battre
annette à pouvoir du territoire national
sous la supervision des autorités
maliennes être et c'est ce qu'on peut
dire que marc khanne est un échec lors
c'est en tout cas le président lui a dit
il en est hors de question c'est pas un
échec etc nous partons en bon ordre et
parce qu'effectivement avec la junte
bien divorce alors divorce est ce que
c'est un échec
je ne sais pas c'est en tout cas une
réussite d'un couple
la france en fait n'avait peut-être
n'avait plus le choix mais cette
décision certains l'ont dit aurait pu
devenir bien plus tôt que cette période
qui est une période très compliquée
parce qu'on le voit que malgré les
succès remporté remporté sur le terrain
qui ont été remportés durant l'été
dernier encore d'autres opérations très
récente et bien les forces françaises
moi quand j'ai été chaque fois sur la
barre et est un pas récemment mais quand
j'y suis allé je voyais bien que la
population se détachait parce que
qu'est-ce qu'elle était le problème de
cette de cette force et que les gens
n'ont pas vu de résultats dans ce qu'ils
attendaient mais ils attendaient quoi un
retour de l'état et s'était pas la
mission effectivement de barkan
d'assurer un retour de l'état c'était à
l'état malien d'assurer les écoles la
santé la justice or ça n'existait plus
dans une tout temps d'une partie
importante du mali et donc ça ils l'ont
reproché à la france ajoutez à cela
effectivement les manipulations sur
l'information mais je crois qu'il ya un
vrai sentiment quand ça marche pas et
bien c'est celui qui est là qui le
pompier de service ou qui est l'ancien
colonisateur qui apporte la
responsabilité donc à aux yeux des
maliens il y à un échec de la france que
le président français d'ischia pas un
échec effectivement il peut
difficilement dire autre chose parce que
pour des mots vis-à-vis de l'armée
française et d'un militaire ya rien de
pire pour un militant de s'entendre dire
que tu as échoué dans leurs chais vous
êtes d'accord c'est un échec de barkan
enfin à mon sens c'est évidemment un
échec diplomatique et militaire ne faut
pas oublier que lorsque l'opération
serval est enclenché les soldats
français et la france est accueilli
comme des libertins comme des
libérateurs et like it le mali en oeuvre
addition avec une humiliation les scouts
la scène que vous venez de diffuser de
cet officier qui dit qui sommes les
français de partir dans les plus brefs
délais et dans l'extrait enfin dans le
c'est en direct sur la télévision
publique il a répété deux fois cette
phrase je répète dit-il nous invitons
donc que dans les plus brefs délais les
forces françaises de quitter le pays
c'est évidemment à
catastrophique pour l'image de la france
dans la sous région c'est un revers et
une claque
qu'à ma connaissance la france n'a pas
connu en afrique de cuir du moins les
indépendances cette manière de vraiment
d'être jetés dehors parce qu'en fait ils
sont pas on leur demande pas de se
retirer ils sont ils sont virés enfin
ils sont conduits à partir ils sont
chassés du mali il mêle max on dit que
c'était prévu ce départ mais bon est-ce
que le débat en fait effectivement
depuis longtemps les militaires
réfléchissent à comment sortir du
bourbier malien parce que c'est un un
bourbier impossible depuis au moins 2016
2017 l'elysée sait très bien que la
sortie sera difficile et mal macron à la
fin du mois de décembre 2017 il est à
peine élu s'interroge sur comment sortir
du piège malien déjà donc il ya déjà
cette inquiétude très nettes
mais pour autant la manière dont ça se
fait c'est absolument catastrophique
pour l'image de la france me semble-t-il
et surtout c'est saluer c'est là aussi
que c'est très inquiétant pour la france
dans tout le sel par la jeunesse c'est à
dire que cette ce geste est une victoire
de la junte sans coup férir sans sang
versé sur l'armée qui les avaient
colonisé il ya une centaine d'années ça
n'a l'air de rien mais symboliquement
c'est extrêmement puissants comme image
et les jeunes gens de bamako à niamey ce
serait jouer aujourd'hui de voir je le
crains le départ de la france dans cet
état piteux charles h et il ya eu des
erreurs de commises du coup oui il ya
des erreurs de commises et tout à
l'heure vous parliez de d'humiliation
pour la france mais elle ne fait
peut-être que commencer dans les brefs
délais dans les plus brefs délais ça
veut dire quoi d'un autre côté emmanuel
macron qui dit
ne pas transiger sur la sécurité quand
on sait qu'une opération pareille
évacué plus de 2000 hommes prendra au
moins de quatre ou six mois certains il
a parlé de six mois ce qui est cour
d'assises parce qu'il est dans les plus
brefs délais
on imagine que c'est encore moi
toute ressemblance avec départ précipité
d'afghanistan des américains à l'été
dernier évidemment involontaire mais
c'est très inquiétant et on peut
imaginer que dans les prochains jours il
y aura une pression de plus en plus
forte sur les sur les français et qui
n'auront pas ces quatre à six mois pour
partir et même s'ils voient enfin
pendant six mois gao enfin si vous
connaissez la base de go c'est une base
immense et l'accueil il est tout les
tout le matériel des trois basques
évacués par les français depuis le mois
de septembre ce sont des milliers et des
milliers de conteneurs si vous vous
aujourd'hui à gao il évident pas
question que c'est ce matériel
reviennent entre les mains de l'armée
malienne parce qu'on sait très bien
sénat devait occuper évidemment tout de
suite par les russes font du moins par
werner comme il s'est passé il ya trois
semaines à tombouctou lorsque les
français ont quitté tombouctou la
première chose qu'on fait le café le
gouvernement malien ces deux d'inviter
les la société werner du mois les russes
à occuper l'ancienne base des français
enfin du point de vue de l'image c'est
absolument désastreux né à la fée wagner
d'ailleurs vote d'autant qu'on va se
retrouver que la saison des pluies qui
va commencer et d'autant qu'il ya déjà
des convois français qui l'a amené des
choses au mali qui ont été pris en otage
sur la route temps au burkina faso au
niger nigeria est effectivement on se
souvient de l'incident de tina où la
force les voeux et françaises oubliées
de tirer pour ceux des angles pour se
désengager il y a eu des morts et des
blessés donc même si la population on
dit est manipulée il n'empêche il y un
vrai sentiment anti-français qui est qui
et qui reflète une évolution
affectivement de l'afrique et je crois
que cette pub c'est c'est la fin de ces
grosses de ces grosses opérations et on
ne faut pas rêver on va pas se
redéployer même un peu différemment à se
redéployer au niger donc si ça lance les
questions à nos forces finalement il
veut bien des petites blois résidents a
dit qu'il était d'accord en tout libre
recevoir la force française que ça il a
dit oui à la frontière des petites bases
mais le président sait qu'il est fragile
qu'il ya des menaces de coups d'état et
qu'il y un fort sentiment anti français
donc il peut pas avoir des gros base il
peut avoir des petites des petits points
des points avancés comme on dit où la
france est présente mais je crois que la
partie en hiver est loin d'être jouée et
laissez pas l'intérêt de la france de
déstabiliser ce pays qui n'est pas aussi
stable que ça non en revanche
effectivement vous avez raison au niger
la situation est beaucoup plus fragile
qu'on ne le dit à paris oui mais en
revanche je me semble que dans le plan
français c'est plutôt aussi un repli sur
les pays je dirais
ça va être les deux piliers du disque du
nouveau dispositif français et ça sera
pas le même type de peine non mais elle
cessera il s'agirait plutôt de chasser
les djihadistes dans le sahel de
contenir la poussée jihadistes pour
protéger les piles coûtant justement ce
raid a perdu la guerre contre les
djihadistes bon là on l'a perdue dès le
départ a été un gagnable vous êtes
d'accord
je suis d'accord avec ça c'est vrai que
d'ailleurs la façon dont la france
prévoit de se redéployer se sont petit
petite base qui seront opérationnels
très rapide un modèle un peu à
l'américaine finalement avec beaucoup
d'actions qui seront par les airs on va
par des drones prêts déjà perdu 80% je
crois des théories sorties qu'elles le
sont par le son de cette manière avec
les problèmes que ça peut poser aussi
parce que ça veut dire moins sécurité
sur le terrain - de sécurité au sol -
informations au sol et donc peut-être
des bavures et des accidents qui
pourront survenir et encore plus de
rejet de la population donc c'est qu'on
est pas très simple il faut se dire très
rapidement c'est que il y as en 2000 en
remuant oui en 2013 au moment de
l'opération c'est le malick est concerné
d'accord c'est le mali aujourd'hui bon
y'a la libye cas qui a explosé voilà on
sait pourquoi est il le mali mais
aujourd'hui c'est le mozambique c'est
tout le nord de la côte d'ivoire c'est
le bénin c'est le togo et c'est une
métastase grand je veux dire c'est c'est
pas une des forces n'est pas un califat
mais c'est des groupes qui se
multiplient démultiplier qui joue sur
les faillites des différents états parce
que les états ont un problème
effectivement je crois de gouvernance
très important en à freiner meira
peut-être au mali alors va être ça le
destin d'alger ce que je ne sais pas
mais une république islamique sans aucun
doute mais où vous savez sous la manière
de la mauritanie on ne dit jamais mais
l'un des piliers du g5 c'est la
mauritanie est une république islamique
donc c'est plutôt ce ce modèle vers
lequel je crois on se dirige mais là
vous avez raison car il faut surtout
comprendre que ces mouvements
djihadistes ou ces groupes armés
s'appuie fin ce soit aussi est liée non
une révolte populaire c'est s'il ya une
insurrection en fait c'est pas
simplement un projet théologico
politique auquel adhère la population
notamment les peuls qu'on dit très
proche de ce mouvement mais c'est
surtout un effectivement là c'est la
périphérie si vous voulez qu'ils se
révoltent contre le centre c'est ce sont
des gens qui veulent à leur tour avoir
une vie à peu près saine normal qu'ils
voient à la télévision comment nous nous
vivons qui joue à lahti lisons comment à
bamako dans les capitales le
représentant vivent et qui concerne que
pour leurs enfants c'est que c'est
extrêmement compliqué que pour aller
dans un centre de santé c'est
extrêmement compliqué et 600000
africains aujourd'hui vivent dans
l'obscurité ces vins sont des conditions
de vie extrêmement difficiles et ils se
disent là c'est une opportunité pour un
autre tour avoir une vie digne et un
horizon dégagé lors leurs six mois est
comment être dessinateur ont-ils croquer
donc à ce retrait ce redéploiement
historique des forces françaises et
européennes du maine là je vous je vous
montrais quatre dessins je vais
évidemment commencer par vous présenter
un dessin de damien langlet qui nous
vient du burkina faso et qui permet de
prendre un peu la température du terrain
dans la région fin de l'opération barkan
au mali on ne me fasse pas c'est moi qui
pars dix soldats français alors qu'il
vient de recevoir un coup de pied aux
fesses par un malien donc vu du mali la
france n'est plus la salvatrice qu'elle
a été en 2013 on l'a dit et vu de la
france il s'agit prendre à petit et de
tirer tant bien que mal les conséquences
échecs français donc tout le monde se
pose la question c'est aussi un échec
malien mine de rien cette autre dessin
aussi très fort du dessine m du
dessinateur américain ed rôle c'est pas
pour rien qu'ils que qu'on a choisi de
vous le présenter parce que la situation
peuvent peut évidemment faire écho avec
le départ des américains d'afghanistan
dont on parlera d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure
et par qui va dégoupillé la grenade du
pire pour pour le mali voilà il est très
très éloquent il se passe de il se passe
de mots un troisième dessin du
dessinateur français la serpe un peu de
son humour acerbe toujours comme
toujours chez chez la serpe justement
sur le rejet de la france au mali
opération barkan la france at elle
échoué par une faute un grand succès
pour la francophonie this ses soldats en
voyant tagué sur un mur la france dehors
quitter le mali indésirables c'est
effectivement ce n'est pas impossible
qu'on écrit mieux le français au mali
qu'en france soit dit en passant c'est
peut-être invendables la leçon c'est la
francophonie et puis pour terminer
encore un dessin de de damien réglée du
du burkina faso qui pour accueillir marc
khanne puisque la france ne quitte pas
totalement le sahel dîner africain à
l'elysée qui va en reprendre tout le
monde voilà aura reconnu le président
ouattara côte d'ivoire le président dieu
du niger on en parlait macky sall du
sénégal voilà on attend de voir comment
ce redéploiement dont on parlait à
l'instant va se faire mais effectivement
le djihadisme encore le terrorisme a
encore de l'avenir dans cette région
bien malheureusement on ne sait pas si
la tente c'était de militaires ou henry
semble s'il la redoute cette présence à
l'europe et à l'ukraine avec ces très
fortes tensions autour de la crise russo
ukrainienne dans le combat sans les
bombardements s'intensifient la russie
assure avoir entamé le retrait de
soldats mais les pays occidentaux jugent
que les mouvements de troupes reflète
une offensive imminente
anthony blinken va par ailleurs
rencontré sergueï lavrov en fin de
semaine prochaine on va écouter anthony
blinken dans le chef de la diplomatie
américaine mais aussi à vladimir poutine
tout ce que nous voyons y compris au
cours des dernières 24 à 48 heures
fait partie d'un scénario déjà en cours
qui consiste à créer de fausses
provocation puis à répondre à ces
provocations
et enfin à commettre une nouvelle
agression contre l'ukraine
tout ce que kiev doit faire c'est
s'asseoir à la table des négociations
avec les représentants du dombass et
s'entendre sur des mesures politiques
militaires économiques et humanitaires
pour mettre fin au conflit est plutôt ça
arrivera mieux ce sera malheureusement
en ce moment on assiste au contraire à
une aggravation de la situation dans la
province
patricia lowe ils l'annoncent il avait
annoncé venir poutine qui avait un
retrait n'est certain nombre de troupes
les américains disent totalement
l'inversé par le même maintenant de 190
mille soldats russes donc aux frontières
aux ukrainiennes d'abord c'était un coup
de bluff de vladimir poutine alors je
pense qu'il faut faire très attention
aux mots employés par vladimir poutine
ce qu'il parle à d'aggravation il est
avec le président biélorusse il a
précisé qu'il allait faire peut-être des
exercices un peu technique avec lui et
donc la crainte effectivement des
occidentaux c'est qu'il installe en
biélorussie des missiles encore plus
près c'est sain c'est anne elle
durablement plus durablement donc quand
à savoir si cette montée parce qu'elle
est il a changé on a bien vu en deux
trois jours cette montée en tension sur
laquelle ils rejouent est ce que le
président russe est toute la question
est ce que le président russe veut aller
à la guerre en prenant par exemple
donbass un cfc là mais réaliste donc
voilà les évacue et pour finalement on a
bien vu pour finalement les indexer
comme il a annexé la crimée est ce que
c'est ça son objectif est-ce que ou
simplement ou alors est-ce que
simplement il veut faire une telle
montée des tensions en particulier sur
cette zone halal est qu'il veut amener
absolument parce qu'il est persuadé qu
ccsa il veut amener les américains a
cédé sur la question effectivement de
l'otan dégagé de toutes les plus
république qui était avant sous la
domination la domination de l'urss ne
pourra pas l'obtenir véritablement sa
charles charles haquet non mais il a un
jeu assez assez ouvert c'est que
vladimir poutine n'est même pas avoir de
marge de manoeuvre étroite il a toujours
montré dans ses vingt ans vingt deux ans
de pouvoir aujourd'hui il s'autorise
toutes les options le son jeu est là et
jusqu'au dernier moment on ne saura pas
ce qui va décider donc on se rend compte
que
chaque pas qu'il est qu'il fait chaque
mouvement qui occasionne en fête permet
d'avancer dans une option mais sans se
priver des autres donc en fait
aujourd'hui personne n'est capable de
dire s'il va attaquer ou pas même si
l'option militaire est effectivement il
a plu la plus lourde la plus dangereuse
et la plus dommageable pour son pays si
tu as vraiment tendu d'ailleurs au
donbass laurent larcher oui c'est
aujourd'hui en tout cas on est ce que ça
va être le prétexte selon parleront tony
blinken pour justement rentrée par ce
biais en tout cas aujourd'hui on assiste
à un scénario qui est vraiment celui ci
du centre qui a eu un attentat attribué
aux pros au succès les ukrainiens
accusent les russes sans fard tout cas
laissé participants d'avoir attaqué
l'école les pro russes disent que c'est
les ukrainiens enfin on a le sentiment
qu'il ya là je dirais le prétexte qu'ils
seraient la russie qui viendrait au
secours de leurs frères pro russe en
ukraine fin du mois dans le donbass en
même temps il est vrai que poutine enfin
quand on écoute vraiment les
spécialistes de la région tous disent
que personne ne croyait vraiment à cette
guerre enfin c'était plutôt une montée
aux extrêmes dans le langage dans la
pression voire dans l'hystérie enfin
chacun ayant un jeu parce que en face on
voyait aussi que du côté américain c'est
il semble qu'en tout cas que cette crise
est au service je dirais une manière
pour faire oublier un peu
aux etats-unis et au président américain
la défaite de kaboul et ils fassent et
ces images-là réapparaître un peu comme
le bouclier contre la russie et et
retrouver le leadership notamment en
europe vis-à-vis de l'otan
c'est très compliqué parce que chacun a
intérêt à caumont dire à cette crise
iront ils jusqu'au bout il est personne
ne peut le dire mais il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui quand même on a une
journée extrêmement tendue
c'est un opportuniste manière très bon
article dans la presse américaine le new
york times sur vladimir poutine et en
exposant de vue en disant que depuis
deux ans depuis le col qu'ovide la
pandémie le président russe était
totalement enfermé dans bouquet risée à
l'intérieur du kremlin il voyait
pratiquement plus personne c'était en
visioconférence c'était justement des
grandes tables comme ça et c'est donc
cédé par le cos vie doivent s'aider
maintenant est ce qui veut dire ce que
selon le jeunesse qui était rentré dans
une phase beaucoup plus ça change un peu
de la psychologie de bas étage que ne
faisait pas ce journaliste un peu de
paranoïa et donc tout le monde lui était
hostile si vous voulez on le menace est
en permanence et dans cette optique là
effectivement il peut mener la guerre
dans l'autre vision qui ont assez que
poutine est effectivement est un grand
joueur et il aime faire monter la
pression jusqu'au dernier bout espérant
faire lâcher ses adversaires là
simplement pour joe biden lâcher c'est
un très mauvais signal qui l'envoie à la
chine parce qu'on ne faut pas oublier
que l'histoire craignant pour baden
c'est aussi l'histoire de taiwan
derrière et que donc s'ils lâchent sur
l'ukraine et laisse l'ukraine envahir
par par vladimir poutine sans rien dire
et bien bon qu à la chine pour taiwan il
faut qu'il montre les muscles charles
charles est il faut qu'il montre les
muscles et c'est vrai que d'en venir
poutine seul en son palais en fait s'il
a quelques
siloviki autour de lui c'est à dire des
spécialistes de la sécurité des vieux
copains du kgb qui sont là ils sont
trois quatre et se sont vraiment ses
hommes de confiance chez avec qui il
discute vraiment c'est étonnant
d'ailleurs de voir que lavrov sergueï
lavrov donc muni des affaires étrangères
n'est pas considéré comme une personne
proche de poutine c'est très difficile
de savoir exactement mais c'est pas
forcément lui qui décide c'est quelqu'un
qu'il consulte mais la diplomatie n'a
jamais le dernier mot par rapport à ces
fameux siloviki et idem pour le ministre
de la défense et qui s'appelle cheikh
bou qui n'est pas non plus fait pas
partie de ces proches donc seule en son
palais les seuls qui le voit
régulièrement ce sont ces fameux ce
conseiller de la sécurité qui sont tous
ancien ou actuel directeur du fsb le
nouveau kgb donc il a une vision quand
même très conditionné du monde extérieur
lorsqu'il va effectivement jusqu'où
va-t-il aller et c'est effectivement la
question qu'on peut se poser cette
question je pose alors en marche et mots
compliqués en tête il ya effectivement
une escalade on peut pas dire qu'ils
aient vraiment une désescalade même si à
un moment donné on a quand même un peu
utilisé mon père me sourit mais en tout
cas tous les spécialistes de poutine
disent que c'est un homme qui décide
seul et là effectivement depuis ses
terres à faire cette guerre c'est aussi
bas on n'a pas l'impression que
l'intérêt de la halle à faire mais oui
mais bon en tout cas il veut absolument
pas que l'ukraine rejoint d'autant voilà
ça c'est la ligne rouge qu'il ne veut
pas il est en train j'ai l'impression
puis met la pression plus d'une certaine
manière il obtient parce que les
européens ne veulent pas de cette guerre
enfin ils n'en veulent pas enfin l'union
européenne est terrorisé à l'idée
et elle s'y prépare mais enfin l'a
terrorisée à l'idée que de devoir
intervenir du moins de devoir assister à
une guerre où quasiment enfin en europe
quand ça reste quand même là depuis l'ex
yougoslavie on avait quand même pas vu
ça je je je crains effectivement que il
à lui il veut il veut pas que l'ukraine
de rejoindre l'otan ça semble assez
clair est il en train d'obtenir ce
résultat parce que qui va par washington
qui va dire oui enfin j'ai pas
l'impression que la france aujourd'hui
par exemple est sur cette position
d'accueillir l'ukraine ou sein du de
l'otan --sept diplomatie autour des
accords de minsk est en ce moment avec
les nouveaux affrontements au sein du
dombass paraît un peu s'éloigner
elle s'éloigne oui mais en même temps le
président poutine s'accroche aujourd'hui
officiellement à ça en disant mais vous
n'avez qu'à vous mettre autour de la
table et discuter tous ensemble et puis
tout sera réglé ça c'est le sait c'est
le discours du le dernier discours du
jour moi je crois qu'ils regardent
beaucoup sur la biélorussie il veut
définitivement annexée enfin même dans
le glacis la biélorussie et ils
positionnait des armes lourdes et des et
des missiles parce que personne ne
regarde effectivement la biélorussie oui
les troubles vont partir mais il reste
un look chic au président biélorusse qui
est totalement inféodée à poutine comme
je sais ce que jamais à éviter les
mouvements est même dit qu'ils seraient
ravis s'ils pouvaient devenir colonel
dans l'armée russe
c'est incroyable de dire ça donc
effectivement il est prêt à accueillir
des missiles nucléaires il ya une s'est
passé une chose hier importante aussi
c'est la douma donc la chambre le
parlement russe les députés ont voté à
très grande majorité le possibilité de
reconnaître les deux républiques
autoproclamées donc sécessionnistes donc
lougansk
dans l'em2 base son cas à l'est c'est
très important parce que si jamais c'est
poutine ou encore une fois il a
progressé dans cette voie dans cette
option si poutine reconnaît ces deux
républiques donetsk est lougansk ça veut
dire que les accords nos ministres sont
morts parce que parce que les accords de
minsk prévoit à un moment ou un autre
que finalement que le l'ukraine que kiev
récupère l'intégralité de son territoire
donc ça veut dire qu'il met fin aux
accords de minsk est alors que tout le
monde parlait des accords de minsk 1
depuis quelques jours de lille alive
chose depuis emmanuel macron comme un
petit peu la voie de la diplomatie alors
comment les dessinateurs ont-ils croquer
croque t-il toujours cette escalade lors
à bien vous savez c'est secret de kriens
et c'est du pain béni pour les
dessinateurs parce qu'on sait en plus à
rebondissements à épisodes le personnage
poutine quand même est très très
alléchant d'eau que j'ai essayé de faire
le tri je vous présenter quatre des cinq
à deux pépites parmi les trente six
mille pépite qu'on a reçu ce cet
incroyable dessin du dessinateur
jordanien osama à jajpur le monde cette
semaine quelle trouvaille franchement
parce que c'est un parfait résumé de la
situation à quoi joue poutine d escalade
bluff ben voilà il a le char caché sous
la nappe de la table des négociations et
on peut dire qu'il a effectivement le
don pour déstabiliser ses adversaires
alors cet autre dessin du dessinateur
belge kroll pour le soir qui est aussi
très bon sur le le retrait des troupes
russes qui a été quand même annoncé
mardi par le kremlin et que kroll
dépeint avec cette étude d'humour très
très belle jeu qui n'est rien qu'à lui
et qu'on lui connaît des escalades point
d'interrogation parce que tout le monde
a été très prudent
ad l'annoncent puis on voit poutine qui
fait volte-face et qui dit si charles
michel l'exigent sur ce ton là on voit
charles michel derrière son pupitre
européen et puis il ya le collaborateur
de poutine dans le char qui dit c'est
qui charles michel voilà un feu tout
dire ça veut tout dire cette ce
troisième dessin aussi du dessinateur
français la sphère washington n'est donc
a très vite été sceptique et puis on
sait que depuis hier donc il se passe
des trucs pas très rassurant dans
donbass mais cela sert il a une petite
idée de la situation en ukraine en
retrait des troupes russes point
d'interrogation ya tu n'y es tu si on
recule c'est pour mieux prendre de
l'élan c'est une technique en effet et
puis pour terminer ce dessin but du
brésil du dessinateur amorim
la seule certitude dans tout ça
effectivement c'est que la crise elle
est loin d'être terminée et que l'europe
va va avoir fort à faire donc du coup
pourquoi pas étendre le linge en
attendant que les choses se calment
entre les deux chars on y vend ça
maintient en tout cas le dialogue s'est
davantage mais ça prouve aussi que e on
est là pour longtemps à mon avis
la hongrie la pologne et bien vont-elles
se soumettre aux règles européennes
l'union européenne dispose d'une
nouvelle arme dans son arsenal un
mécanisme qui permet de bloquer les
fonds européens allant au pays justement
qui remettent en cause l'état de droit
et la justice européenne a validé alors
patricia l'europe renforce son
dispositif est ce que finalement elle va
y aller cette fois et elle va être plus
ferme parce que ça fait plusieurs années
qu'on parle de ce bras de fer entre la
hongrie la pologne et l'europe il
fallait des décisions à l'unanimité avec
ce dispositif 15 une majorité voilà de
15 états va suffire alors le dispositif
est là la cour de justice européenne a
dit ok bon qu il faut y aller simplement
à l'europe attend apparemment la cheffe
de la comédie bien qu'ils allaient
étudier les le pourquoi de cette
décision des juges qui n'en a même pas
été question à bruxelles alors voilà
alors on va étudier et on attend donc
les donc la tante peuvent se poursuivre
alors pourquoi c'était pourquoi cette
frilosité de la commission applique et
finalement les décisions qui sont tombés
de la courge du si c'est clair net et
précis alors certains maîtres des
hypothèses effectivement les chefs
d'état européens sont pas si alan la
france a peut être un peu négocier sur
le nucléaire avec la hongrie d'autres
ont un peu négocier d'autres choses avec
eux la pologne donc si vous voulez ils
sont pas aussi alan que ça leur tordre
le bras alors que ce serait magistral
quand même comme comme mesure et puis il
y a les élections qui vont arriver en
hongrie alors que telle chose au mois de
mars voilà un faut-il attendre les
élections de hongrie avant d'aller au
plus à merci la hongrie changé c'est
l'opposition pro européenne qui qui
gagne ces élections
est-ce qu'on va agir seul contre la
pologne et puis la pologne maintenant
des bien embêté d'agir a en ce moment
donc on voit que la commission
européenne vient prend son temps charles
haquet elle prend son temps elle a pris
son temps pendant des années aujourd'hui
les bons instruments et prend toujours
attend toujours son temps nucléaire en
pologne où si oui ce qu'un appel
d'offres oui l'acteur
d'origine nucléaire qui est parti mais
attend de cette énergie vers
l'europe on a l'impression que que le
l'europe ne veut pas se prononcer avant
le 3 avril la date de l'élection
législative en gripas avril donc parce
que il ya un vrai problème c'est que
l'opposition que l'on dit très soudés en
voie de battre enfin à victor ban après
quatre mandats ballet pas en si bonne
forme que ça où il se trouve que le
candidat peut être marre qu'ils aillent
qui a réussi à fédérer autour de lui
tous les partis d'opposition la
coalition des six parties elle n'est pas
en très bonne forme il soit un mois 40
42 43 % ça descend ça baisse or ban est
un maître dans l'art de de trouver des
boucs émissaires et là l'idée de se
servir de l'europe qui va toucher la
hongrie au coeur enfin plutôt
portefeuille mais bon et les méchants
européen c'est ça risque d'alimenter
effectivement son discours est de
favoriser
de favoriser la rancune contre les
européens même si le pays est très pro
européens d'un autre côté donc je pense
qu'il ya une hésitation qui est de
l'ordre politique ce qu'il faut et
stratégiquement attaquer et vraiment se
prononcer avant les élections ou après
il est évident que ces élections et 3
avril bloquent complètement vous fichent
complètement la situation il s'agirait
pas de données ou dut ou de moins de
faire basculer l'opinion publique en
hongrie du côté des de ceux qui désirent
quitter la l'union européenne et puis il
faut rappeler que la crise en ukraine
fait qu' il est vrai enfin les 100 mo ti
lil n'est pas du tout le moment de se
fâcher violemment avec la hongrie et la
pologne la pologne est quand même
concerné aussi par ce qui se passe sur
sa frontière orientale et justement elle
pourrait reculer la pologne parce que
comme elle est aujourd'hui concerné par
la menace russe elle pourrait dire bon
bien d'accord j'accepte que passe
d'ailleurs il me semble qu'elle a essayé
de céder un petit peu sur les juges et
puis finalement elle s'est dérobé enfin
du point de vue de l'europe en tout cas
c'est pas du tout son intérêt de phase
i/ii comment dire de sanctionner l'un de
ses états membres à un moment où une
guerre état sur son flanc oriental c'est
de la grande île ce serait de la folie
du point de vue stratégique frs et pour
le la stabilité du continent la
stabilité de l'union européenne c'est le
moment le plus d'autant que on sait bien
la russie la hongrie sont calmes à ses
proches enfin on peut imaginer je dirais
d une accentuation de la crise au sein
des états membres qui serait
catastrophique un mouvement politique et
prend le dessus sur les valeurs
exactement est très simple alors que
c'est une arme redoutable ces nouveaux
moyens ah oui de couper les vivres serre
aux états est une arme c'est une arme
redoutable elle elle peut l'exercer
jamais avant ça ne s'était produit et
ont effectivement ces deux pays ont un
besoin énorme temps des fonds européens
qui sont importants c'est près de 100
milliards d'euros jusqu'en 2025 que des
coûts du plan de relance
mais de toute façon même s'ils veulent
se presser il faudra six à neuf mois
pour mettre ça en place
c'est ça mais mais mais c'est vrai que
ils vont peut-être être obligés quand
même à bruxelles de se bouger un peu
parce que le parlement parlement est
très actif comme effet une procédure
contre contre la commission en disant
qu'est ce que vous attendez alesi donc
peut-être qu'il va se passer des choses
donc après la crise ukrainienne après
les élections on grille un bref merci en
tout cas sur ce sujet les dessinateurs
oui alors 3 3 dessins assez cocasse on
commence par un premier dessin du
dessinateur français rodo très bien vu
pologne hongrie privés des fonds
européens du plan de relance puis on
voit les dirigeants polonais et hongrois
kis extrêmes nous faire le coup de la
discrimination à nous les spécialistes
c'est sûr que la pologne l'engrais qui
menacent de bloquer l'union européenne
parce que l'union européenne leur
refusent les flancs du plan de relance
sous prétexte que les deux pays ne
respectent pas l'état de droit et les
valeurs européennes
c'est le cri morel dessinatrice
française aussi qui résume bien respect
de l'état de droit la seule valeur
européenne on accepte sellers euros
10les petite étoile polonaise phrase
sécurité en somme et puis pour terminer
ce dessinateur de ce dessin du
dessinateur français placide vous savez
c'est toujours très utile pour les
dessinateurs de presse de transposer des
situations politiques dans la sphère
domestique
on comprend tout de suite beaucoup mieux
la complexité des situations parfois
hélas on voit madame ursula von der
leyen qui se dit je leur donne trop
d'argent de poche aux petits au petit
dernier et
c'est vrai qu'ils ont un petit peu
d'aidé tête de sales gosses et qui
prennent ils prennent de mauvaises
habitudes donc même si c'est pas encore
une réalité les dessinateurs de presse
voilà on imaginer ce que ça pourrait
donner
l'afghanistan simon après la chute de
kaboul et la prise du pouvoir par les
talibans le pays est meurtri par la
famine l'économie sinistrée les femmes a
banni des écoles de l'espace public ou
encore du monde du travail joe biden
prévoit de consacrer la moitié des 7
milliards de dollars d'actifs afghans à
l'indemnisation des victimes
les attentats du 11 septembre 2001
l'autre moitié devrait être reversée
sous forme d' aide humanitaire en
afghanistan c'est une décision qui
suscite bien sûr l'indignation des
afghans on va écouter l'ancien président
afghan hamid karzaï était interrogé par
marc perelman dans une interview
exclusive pour france 24 ce sont les
avoirs du peuple afghan
et le peuple
est tout autant une victime que les
victimes de la tragédie du 11 septembre
est donc au fait que le président byden
saisissent la moitié des réserves
nationales et qu'il les halles ou à ses
victimes
il s'agit là d'un déni du statut de
victime du peuple afghan c'est
moralement répréhensible et donc j'y
suis fortement opposés je suis opposé à
cette décision nous voulons que
l'intégralité de ses avoirs soient
réservés à l'afghanistan adressé à laon
le taliban les talibans ne sont toujours
pas reconnue par la communauté
internationale pour bien le spécifier
cette décision américaine elle suscite
l'indignation bon effectivement l'ancien
président mais un peu de l'ensemble des
afghans d'ailleurs elle sera
effectivement y'a bien un texte de loi
qui permet à dubaï donne de fait
exceptionnel qui permet de faire de
prendre cette mesure mais ça sera pas
facile à mettre en place aux états unis
parce qu'il va avoir des contestations
mais ce qui était drôle c'est qu'hamid
karzaï est tout à fait sur la même
longueur d'onde que les talibans là
parce que s'il est resté d'ailleurs dans
le pays c'est ce que disent les talus
les talibans aujourd'hui enfin l'état
islamique en afghanistan a deux
objectifs un rogue avoir la
reconnaissance internationale
ça c'est sur un plan plus symbolique et
puis l'autre c'est récupérer de l'argent
des orange et des nations unies d'avoir
de l'aide est donc là effectivement
c'est une pierre qui ne les arrange pas
qu'elle leur a lancé joe biden mais on
le voit mais aussi à tout prix de
séduire la communauté internationale ils
sont allés à oslo israël et genève ils
sont allés là récemment au qatar est
sans fin ils vont partout pour essayer
de dire de l'aide de l'aide de l'adc
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils font des
pièces ils viennent de libérer quatre
femmes je crois qu'il avait emprisonné
enfin voyez ils font des petits et sa
marque là en tout cas le dessin des
femmes ne s'arrange pas vraiment
j'imagine qu'il m'adresse à vous le
savez ça avec j'ai vu l'onu qui voit qui
en fait affirment que les talibans
tentent d'effacer progressivement les
femmes et les filles de la vie publique
en afghanistan la répression qui vise
particulièrement les militantes les
dirigeants de la société civile les
femmes les juges procureurs les membres
des forces de sécurité les journalistes
les fonctionnaires plusieurs dont on
était disparue donc certaines ont été
les rs que vous décidiez quelques petits
gestes qui se ferme et enfin on voit
bien que tout tout ce qui pouvait
symboliser une liberté c'est-à-dire les
femmes la liberté la liberté de marché
les femmes sont le plus bel exemple mais
les journalistes c'est exactement pareil
ils sont arrêtés 80 radio et tintin
c'est une chape de plomb qui se mêlent
aux journalistes afghans c'est à dire
qu'il laisse l'accès aux journalistes et
leurs nationaux mais oui par pour
montrer cette image montrait qu'ils sont
sympathiques vis-à-vis des journalistes
finalement internationaux et surtout ils
ont tellement besoin de ces vivres
qu'ils sont prêts à montrer que toutes
leurs populations meurent de faim pour
nous apitoyer charles haquet c'est vrai
qu'alors la situation humanitaire est
terrible 1 38 million d'habitants sur
les 38 millions d'habitants du pays 23
millions sont menacées par la famine
selon
l'onu ça il ya 41 % des enfants qui sont
victimes de malnutrition qui ont des
problèmes de croissance qui sont en
déficit de croissance ya une famille sur
trois qui n'a pas du tout de ressources
donc effectivement on est dans une
situation économique qui est dramatique
et un état taliban puisque même s'il est
pas reconnu ils ont un rôle d'états qui
n'arrivent pas à enclencher à faire
revenir une une activité économique on
est passé d'une économie de rente aussi
avec plus de 8 milliards de dollars 2
dead a accordé à l'état un budget là les
talibans le budget de cette année c'est
400 millions d'euros c'est à dire qu'ils
n'ont plus aucune ressource pour eux
pour à l'ange pas forcément des fonds
des talibans il ya plus de ressources
pour relancer la machine économique les
élites sont partis les entreprises
afghane en licencier plus de 60% des
personnels donc le pays est vraiment à
l'arrêt c'est un pays je suis juste un
petit il était déjà mal en point avant
le chan y avait déjà 40% ou 50% près de
50% de la population qui vivait déjà qui
était au bord de la famine déjà avant
donc ça a explosé c'est exposer à
laurent larcher mais c'est là où je
comprends pas bien là la décision de joe
biden parce que en bloquant ses essais
ses 7 milliards de dollars
comment dire il va resserrer semble-t-il
la légitimité du régime taliban au
propre aux yeux de sa population c'est à
dire que cette population qui
effectivement d'une situation dramatique
vous avez donné des chiffres qui sont
juste exceptionnellement tragique
l'afghanistan qui était déjà avant les
talibans l'un des pays les plus pauvres
du monde se trouve là à faire la
population se trouve là encore plus
sanctionnées par par la décision de
washington fin du mois de juillet et
enfin l'annnonce de java de sorte que
politiquement enfin je joue je vois pas
du tout l'intérêt que je vais pas faire
de cela parce qu'il renforce son hôte il
faille risque de renforcer une forme de
front et d'unité nationale autour d'un
régime qui pourront en tout cas
occidentaux pose un vrai problème mary
se renforçait la détermination des
talibans mais franchement la population
les soutiens pas et je dors pas même
dans les endroits jeunette corps etc il
ya une partie de la population va être
triste dire qu'il faut pas non plus à
mon sens
il y à la population des villes bien sûr
à la campagne 24 ans et on sait bien
qu'on a une des régions les plus
conservatrices installé dans aussi une
assise populaire comme importante il
n'aurait pas remporté le faire vivre
leur victoire quand même manifeste aussi
je dirais un soutien important alors il
difficile de le quantifier bien sûr mais
leur programme n'est pas un programme
marginal en afghanistan lors lors simoes
les dessinateurs pour terminer oui on a
un premier dessin du dessinateur
français cambon qui qui est très fort
sur justement la situation des femmes
afghanes afghanistan six mois après et
toujours pas de convoi de la liberté dit
cette femme sous sa burqa c'est qui
tacle en passant au s'impatiente égard
on voit la liberté mais on adorerait
justement voir mobiliser tous ses jambes
des convois la liberté dans la rue pour
dénoncer la dictature talibane qui est
en cours cet autre dessin du dessinateur
néerlandais scheer brouillard comme si
même si les talibans ne suffisait pas il
ya aussi la famine on l'a dit et les
talibans ont précipité davantage le pays
dans une crise économique qui plonge la
population dans une pauvreté
terrible et puis pour terminer ce dessin
de la serbe pour siné mensuel préférence
mais qui dit aussi toute la
déshumanisation qui qui a cours dans le
pays terrible famine dans l'afghanistan
on a plus que la burqa sur les os le
langage change pige juste terminée pour
quand même rappeler que la liberté de la
presse patricia l'adie a vraiment du
souci à ce faire aussi et que cartooning
for peace avec d'autres partenaires mais
notamment reporters sans frontières en
tête on a aidé à faire sortir de kaboul
des dessinateurs de presse qui était
sérieusement menacé vous imaginez et qui
et puis voilà il ya plein d'associations
et d'acteurs qui continue sur mobile et
pour soutenir ceux qui sont encore sur
place a résisté tant bien que mal merci
lors laure simon s merci beaucoup
charles inquiet d'avoir été avec nous
merci laurent larcher merci patricia
patricia allemonière et puis merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivis pour
rester avec nous sur france 24
[Musique]